bonsoir le 7-8 l'actu sur tv fil 78
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale voici
les titres de ce 23 janvier 2014 les
nouveaux rythmes scolaires devront être
appliquées dès le mois de septembre est
les villes doivent s'organiser
l'éducation nationale souhaite que tout
soit réglé avant les prochaines
municipales l'école troisième c'est lent
pour partenaire des prix lumières lundi
soir à paris la presse étrangère décerné
ses récompenses les élèves de
l'établissement et binoy était aux
premières loges à l'annoncé du palmarès
et puis découverte du krav maga c'est
une méthode d'autodéfense tchécoslovaque
de nombreuses polices et troupes d'élite
dans le monde de la pratique elle
connaît également un succès grandissant
chez les particuliers découverte donc de
cette discipline avec des cours qui sont
dispensés dans la ville de guyancourt
quelques chiffres pour débuter ceux de
la délinquance dans les yvelines alors
qu'hier les policiers manifestaient dans
le département déplorant manque de
moyens et difficultés à assurer leur
mission l'observatoire national de la
délinquance vient de publier son rapport
annuel dans les yvelines donc les
atteintes aux biens constatées par la
police augmentent de plus d'un pour cent
en 2013 progression encore plus forte
des vols sans violence et avec violence
destruction dégradation sont en
régression de 5,4 points on notera cette
hausse des violences sexuelles +17 5%
est du côté de la gendarmerie elles sont
aussi en hausse les atteintes aux biens
et aux vols sans violence en revanche
les vols avec violence diminuent de 10
9% et quelques ainsi que les violences
sexuelles des chiffres qui sont à mettre
en relation avec le reste de la france
où l'on assiste surtout à la progression
des cambriolages je vous en parlais hier
soir déjà ump udf ont finalisé leur
accord de soutien pour les municipales
dans les yvelines pas de surprise si ce
n'est à maurepas si les candidats des
deux formations ne fusionne pas à leur
liste les investitures serait tout
simplement retiré voici les à maurepas
l'ump et lui dédie donneront une
investiture commune à une liste d'union
rinne el gahs restiez en l'absence d'une
telle liste d'union ump ait eu des lions
décidé de retirer les deux investiture
donné sur cette ville le communiqué est
signé de la fédération départementale de
l'ump depuis plusieurs mois les deux
hommes s'opposent sur la ville d'un côté
pierre leguérinel ancien premier adjoint
du maire sortant georges mougeot vice
président de l'uwe dei dans les yvelines
et qui se présente avec sur sa liste
nicole malaquin ancienne candidate ump
en 2008 de l'autre cas il aurait garé
astier responsable local de l'ump qui
revendique cinq adhérents de l'udf sur
sa liste deux hommes impossibles à
mettre d'accord donc et malgré la
pression aujourd'hui exercées par leur
formation les choses ne devraient pas
changer moi j'ai proposé que pour que
tout le monde sorte par le haut que
celui qui souhaite absolument être
candidat soit numéro 3 puisque c'est un
homme donc une heure ou deux il ne peut
pas il siégera avec moi à
l'intercommunalité et je lui ai demandé
de réfléchir à la délégation qu'il
souhaitait avoir de façon à acquérir une
expérience qu aujourd'hui n'a pas mais
ce que lui dit d'ailleurs l'ump j'ai
entendu devant moi dire qu'il n'avait
pas l'expérience nécessaire
le seul souci c'est pour ces réunions il
faut pouvoir discuter et si vous faites
ça c'est quelqu'un qui de toute façon ne
veut pas discuter par la discussion
je suis persuadé que je serai en fête
premier tour et je pense que monsieur le
garde et le sait donc il est fait de se
trouver une porte de sortie donc moi
cela ne m'intéresse pas je trace ma
route mon équipe a les complète ma liste
à l'effet est donc que je ne vois pas
pourquoi je ferais une alliance avec que
celui qui était le premier adjoint d'un
maire hôte cocher une majorité
socialiste pendant six ans et qui a fait
perdre la droite en 2008 bien le
guérinel qui précise qu' à aucun moment
lui d in envisagerait de lui retirer son
investiture même s'il devait se
présenter seul le discours est moins
affirmatif grégory guerre et astier on
n'en est pas là nous verrons les choses
dans les semaines qui viennent mais en
tout cas moi ma position à l'éclair et
nous verrons ce qui adviendra en tout
cas je reste le responsable ump de la
ville de maurepas prochaine étape du
bras de fer ce week end avec un point
presse comme un très attendu de valérie
pécresse et d'arnaud richard les deux
présidents dans les yvelines de l'ump et
de lui dit
elle nous reparlons des municipales tout
à l'heure nous ferons le point sur les
changements à attendre lors du scrutin
ce qui va changer pour les électeurs les
rythmes scolaires ils vont changer eux
aussi dès la rentrée vous avez
d'ailleurs peut-être participer à des
ateliers dans votre ville pour mettre en
place dans de meilleures conditions
cette réforme nous avons voulu savoir si
les communes dans les yvelines était
prête les cours vont ils se dérouler le
mercredi ou le samedi et surtout quelles
seront les activités qui seront
proposées aux enfants sur ces nouveaux
temps libre à venir lyonnaise
à maurepas l'ump et l'udf donneront les
rythmes scolaires c'est pour septembre
et le mercredi semble pour le moment
l'emporter sur le samedi à bois d'arcy
mort par voisins le bretonneux montigny
le bretonneux ou encore guyancourt le
temps d'enseignement supplémentaire sera
instauré le mercredi matin de 8h30 à
11h30 un choix validé suite aux
concertations menées auprès des parents
d'élèves et des partenaires du monde
éducatif local ce passage à la semaine
de quatre jours et demi doit alléger le
rythme de travail quotidien des enfants
en semaine ils auront donc trois heures
de temps libre en plus du temps qui sera
alors réservé aux nouveaux temps
d'activités périscolaires
certaines communes du département sont
en train d'affiner le contenu de ces
nouveaux temps libre à voisins le
bretonneux 8ème ont déjà été retenus il
y en a 8 1 qui sont autour bien sûr de
l'expression corporelle l'expression
artistique mais aussi la citoyenneté la
santé aussi ça nous a semblé être un
thème important en ce moment l'éducation
à la santé à l'alimentation
autre conséquence de cette réforme pour
les municipalités l'organisation des
locaux à voisins le bretonneux toujours
on a fait le choix d'ouvrir tous les
groupes scolaires de la ville le
mercredi après midi
aujourd'hui nous avons deux groupes
scolaires ouverts le mercredi
pour les six groupes scolaires de
voisins et bien là nous avons pris une
décision importante mais qui nous
semblait nécessaire pour maintenir au
maximum les repères aux enfants nous
allons ouvrir les six centres de loisirs
dans les six groupes scolaires le
mercredi autre ville guyancourt ici les
discussions se poursuivent à partir la
semaine prochaine
équipes de la ville vont aller
rencontrer des équipes enseignantes
puisque il faut aussi qu'on voyait
l'aménagement des salles que nous on va
utiliser alors donc on va travailler
groupe scolaire par groupes scolaires
puisque les problématiques sont
différents d'une école à une autre dans
certaines écoles on a des centres de
loisirs d'autant n'a pas donc il faut
effectivement qu'on va et l'organisation
des salles quel sera le coût de ces
changements à guyancourt on évoque pour
le moment au montant de 300 mille euros
tandis qu'à voisins le bretonneux on
prévoit 240000 euros de dépenses sur les
prochains budgets soit 200 à 300 euros
par enfant et par an le recrutement
d'animateurs supplémentaire est aussi à
prendre en compte dans leur budget à
noter que pour la première année
d'application de la réforme l'état met à
disposition des communes 50 euros par
élève et 90 euros dans les zones en
difficulté s'y ajoute une prestation
versée par les caisses d'allocations
familiales de 50,3 euros par an et par
enfant quoi qu'il en soit l'inspection
académique devra récupérer l'ensemble
des projets avant la fin du mois de juin
même si à elancourt on refuse toujours
de s'y soumettre
le maire souhaite quelque chose de plus
consensuel on a fait nos trois
concertation une avec les profs une avec
les parents d'élèves et une avec nono
animateurs bon dans les trois cas on a
en bien senties clairement qu' il y
avait plutôt un avis négatif qui se
dégageait je vais pas m'opposer pour me
poser simplement là il faut qu'on prouve
quand monsieur peillon sera capable de
m'expliquer que ça améliore les rythmes
scolaires et que c'est qui me dira
qu'ils financent exactement comment on
finance et qui finance à voir combien ça
coûte il ne sait même pas combien ça
coûte qui financent et surtout quelle
est la valeur ajoutée trois enfants moi
c'est ça qui est déterminant dans le
département des yvelines neuf communes
dont celle de trappes appliquent déjà la
semaine de quatre jours et demi depuis
l'invité de cette édition à présent et
ce soir c'est fabien fourniront bonsoir
bonsoir est directeur de la
communication des 3e 3e c'est l'institut
international de l'image et du son école
basé à elancourt partenaires des prix
lumières qui récompensent le cinéma
français et francophone est 19ème
cérémonie de remise de prix lundi
dernier à paris en quoi consistaient
consiste ce partenariat alors devant les
lumières site une manifestation qui
existe depuis dix neuf ans nous sommes
partenaires de 2 des prix lumières
maintenant depuis deux ans et je dirais
qu'on a même monté d'un cran à cette
année puisque nous sommes devenus fait
coproducteur de la manifestation donc en
fait en quoi ça consiste
très concrètement on a géré une
cinquantaine d'étudiants donc sur place
toutes filières confondues puisqu'on
fait 3e sous forme j'irai des
techniciens et on va dire des
réalisateurs enfin dans plusieurs
domaines cinéma audiovisuel
les arts numériques spectacle vivant et
journalisme donc tout ce petit monde en
fait à travailler conjointement avec une
synergie
concrètement il ya eu donc toute la
captation donc de la soirée
exactement une image qui sont signés
troisième qui sont signés des étudiants
voilà absolument donc la captation
mais évidemment la mise en lumière et
son de tout l'espace donc pierre cardin
et puis également de couverture
médiatique puisque nous avons relayé
donc en live tweet toute la soirée
et l'animation d'un blog dédié donc à la
soirée donc des lumières exercice
grandeur nature donc pour tous ces
élèves juste vous rappeler quelques uns
des des lauréats la vie d'adèle meilleur
film meilleur réalisateur pour
abdellatif kechiche justement pour la
vie d'adèle meilleures actrices léa
seydoux meilleur acteur guillaume
gallienne dans les garçons et guillaume
qui a rencontré un grand succès en
salles on le sait et qui a été
distinguée lors de la cérémonie du 10
exercice grandeur nature pour pour ces
élèves ils s'en sont bien sortis oui
écouter ils s'en sont bien sorties et je
crois que d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu
dans l'adn de l'école c'est de les
mettre dans des conditions faire
diversion professionnels donc c'est un
exercice qui le connaissent qu'ils
pratiquent d'ailleurs de l'entreprise
même gérer sur le plan local puisqu'ils
sont amenés à travailler sur le prism
par exemple et le spectacle sur la ville
d'elancourt absolument absolument et bon
peut-être un scoop mais
les la cérémonie des césar sera aussi
assurée par nos étudiants au niveau de
la captation qui sera ensuite rediffusé
sur les réseaux sociaux et le web avec
justement l'académie des césars vous
aviez un partenariat déjà plus anciens
avec oui oui et on a souhaité
le continuer puisque c'est toujours une
logique en fait de professionnalisation
de nos étudiants ça leur apporte quoi
vous allez ça leur montre que
concrètement comment n'importe être
servis ou comment technique faut réagir
anticipé on est en direct voilà vous
êtes dans des conditions donc de direct
donc il nous faut anticiper sa demande
des capacités d'organisation de
réactivité aussi importantes sont
supervisés par des enseignantes alors
voilà on les lâche pas comme ça dans la
nature bien entendu ils sont encadrés
par leurs référents et toute une équipe
pédagogique et l'idée est bien entendu
qui le qu'ils en tient en fait les
enseignements et puis les erreurs aussi
agir on n'est pas à l'abri aussi d'un
d'un problème technique donc ça aussi
ils doivent aussi le surmonter c'est ce
qu'ils devront faire plus tard aussi et
c'est bon pour leur carnet d'adressés
également alors aussi ça se sent sur ce
genre de rendez-vous ça permet de ses
valeurs alors d'avoir des contacts oui
d'abord ce ne sont pas que nous enfin
n'importe quelle manifestation et puis
effectivement l'idée pour eux c'est de
capitaliser
et de l'inscrire aussi donc dans leur
parcours puisqu'on sait aussi ce sont
des métiers de réseaux donc plus
rencontrant roman les pluies seront
gérés amené à se confronter à ce genre
de situation est évidemment c'est très
bon pour la servir les lumières les
césars l'école bénéficie d'une bonne
renommée que deviennent les élèves
justement ça s'est passé par châteauroux
nos élèves ont fait s'ils sont amenés
oui faso a mené en fait à travailler
dans différents indifférent différents
endroits j'irai que la 3e aujourd'hui
forment en fait d'eux des professions de
contenu alors on est vraiment dans les
industries créatives aujourd'hui quand
je parle de contenu c'est le cinéma
c'est la télé mais pas que c'est le
domaine du spectacle vivant c'est ce
sont les concerts les arts scéniques
l'animation le jeu vidéo mais aussi la
publicité et tout le contenu que peuvent
générer aujourd'hui les entreprises
parce qu'on sait aujourd'hui que ce qui
fait une entreprise et ses produits et
ses marques se sont aussi l'eau les
contenus on en revient à ce prix à ces
prix des lumières dans le cadre du
partenariat il ya aussi toute une
programmation spéciale qui se met en
place dans les salles d'elancourt les
salles de cinéma d'elancourt et des
clayes-sous-bois la belgique qui était à
l'honneur vous avez participé à
l'élaboration de ce programme alors le
programme en fête a été élaboré par le
centre wallonie-bruxelles et on remercie
et qui nous a beaucoup épaulée pour pour
remonter pour monter ce programme on l'a
voulu assez
éclectique et
voilà en tenant compte aussi de des
publics que nous allons donc avoir sur
place pour monter donc cette semaine de
rétrospective mais pas que c'est à dire
aussi d'avant-premières bien chance
d'activant dès mardi la première la
première avant première de cette série
c'était le sac de farine ou on va revoir
d'ailleurs quelques images de la
protection élus au 7 mars au ciné cette
à elancourt en présence de l'équipe du
film il y aura d'autres avant-premières
aussi au cours de la semaine absolument
donc il y aura une autre avant-première
donc le dimanche à 18h30 toujours donc
aussi beau signer 7 le film s'appelle je
te survivrai essai du réalisateur
sylvestre ce bilan voilà donc de ne
rater pas en fait ce film dont on n'a
pas souvent l'occasion d'avoir donc des
réalisateurs et des équipes qui se
déplacent en général elle se déplace
toujours un petit peu dans les mêmes
salles et là je crois que nous c'était
une vraie volonté c'est de faire venir
des réalisateurs à la rencontre donc des
publics locaux ça aussi c'est important
pour nous l'ancrage local implanté
l'école sur son sort sur ce territoire
et puis on imagine aussi pour les
étudiants c'est l'occasion de compléter
leurs connaissances de s'ouvrir à
l'ensemble des cinémas l'on n'est pas
sûr du blockbuster nez sur des films
d'auteur oui oui on peut le cinéma belge
aussi je dirais c'est un cinéma qui
marche bien enfin et la culture belge
d'ailleurs en général mais oui
effectivement on a eu des master class
et puis je dire que bon pour avoir
assisté à l'avant-première de mardi moi
j'ai senti un public extrêmement comment
dire
volontaire et active qui a posé beaucoup
de questions est bon la réalisatrice
comme smaïn aussi sont vraiment prêté au
jeu des questions vous restez avec nous
encore en plateau fabien fournier on va
parler des cordées de la réussite cela
concerne aussi votre établissement le
label des cordées de la réussite a été
lancé en 2008 par l'état il propose aux
jeunes des rencontres dans des instituts
d'enseignement supérieur dont 3 yes
c'était vendredi dernier olivier
maniscalco et jonathan vilma
découvrir de nouveaux métiers pour
élargir ses perspectives d'avenir c'est
ce que propose tout au long de l'année
le label des cordées de la réussite en
organisant des ateliers rencontres entre
collégiens lycéens et instituts
d'enseignement supérieur
ainsi vendredi dernier une centaine
d'élèves se rendait à l'institut image
et son troisième d'elancourt l'occasion
pour eux de découvrir les métiers du
cinéma de l'audiovisuel du journalisme
ou encore du spectacle vivant et même de
s'improviser perchiste l'idée c'est de
les mettre en situation je dormais un
micro une berge et vieillissent pose des
questions entre eux ils échangent et ils
appréhendent du coup le leçons de cette
manière là c'est de leur montrer que ce
qu'ils apprennent à l'école ça peut leur
ouvrir des portes pour plein de choses
qu'ils imaginent pas forcément en
l'occurrence les métiers du cinéma c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on qui paraît
accessible tout de suite pour un
cantonné au lycée au collège et balla de
voir ça de l'appréhender va ça peut
donner envie d'aller voir autre chose
que de se montrer d'ouvrir des horizons
autre atelier découverte organisé le
studio radio reçu par deux animateurs
étudiants troisième les lycéens ont pu
s'initier à l'exercice journalistique
j'avais pas que c'était aussi compliqué
de lancer un débat
pouvoir avant de la répartie de poser
des questions quand il ya des blancs
ces milieux là
et oui aussi à des camarades qui sont
avec moi qui sont intéressé aussi par
tout ça par l'audiovisuel les rêves
prennent forme mais les formations coûte
toujours cher pour des élèves issus de
milieux modestes à troisième s'il faut
débourser pas moins de 7000 euros pour
une année d'enseignement l'établissement
privé tente néanmoins de trouver un
accord avec les collectivités pour
recevoir des étudiants boursiers
hec essec écoles polytechniques des noms
prestigieux d'établissement qui sont
labellisés en quelque sorte cordées de
la réussite et il faut donc ajouter 3 y
est ça l encours l'institut de l'image
et du son en tout il ya huit
établissements qui participent aux
cordées de la réussite pour ceux qui
viennent nous rejoindre on peut re
préciser ce qu'est ce dispositif
peut-être cordées de la réussite à quoi
ça sert oui alors les cordées de la
réussite fait c'est un dispositif
voilà nationale donc ils dépendent du
ministère de l'éducation est notre
mission puisque c'est vraiment une
mission c'est en fait de montrer donc à
des élèves collégiens ou lycéens que
tout est possible
c'est en fait lutter contre une
autodétermination à l'autodétermination
qui peut être soit du un contexte social
familial mais aussi
aux élèves eux mêmes qui peuvent se dire
non je n'y arriverai pas je ne pourrais
pas donc c'est cette facette journée et
puis aussi tous les événements nous
organiserons enfin cette année puisque
là c'était dans le cadre d'une journée
en fête nationale évidemment on va aussi
prolonger enfin cher ces événements tout
au long de l'année c'est voilà c'est de
leur montrer que d'abord on peut faire
des études supérieures
mais aussi qu'on peut travailler dans le
domaine du cinéma il ya une politique
spécifique est mis en place pour
l'égalité des chances à troisième au
niveau des élèves qui intègrent
l'établissement est ce que vous faites
attention à la diversité des parcours
ont signé des horizons bien sûr on a
tous types de fer d'origine de
bacheliers il faut évidemment avoir le
bac vont pouvoir rentrer à l'école mais
il n'y a aucune aucune limitation soit
je crois que c'est surtout la motivation
ça on est très très comment dire
sensible à ce genre de choses et puis
bon la passion à la fiction ce sont des
métiers où il faut beaucoup persévérer
rien est acquis mais on l'est on les
aide depuis 2010 vont participer aux
cordées de la réussite 2010 le bilan
avait coûté les élèves que pour
l'établissement alors oui il ya à
plusieurs titres d'abord c'est le gérer
250 élèves qui sont mal accueillis
chaque année
c'est jamais la même main c'est jamais
la même chose en fait chaque année et ce
qui est surtout intéressant c'est qu'on
a donc des étudiants qui vont jouer un
bon rôle de grand frère
voilà c'est une sorte de passation de
transmissions alors de savoir ce serait
peut-être un petit peu prétentieux parce
qu'on dispose sont des événements qui
sont assez court mais en tout cas
d'envié et le format est gérée elle
s'est adaptée parce que ça permet de
découvrir assez rapidement différents
métiers et puis les compétences et
savoir que ça peut ça peut décider
éventuellement de futurs élèves donc
pour l'établissement voilà fabien
fournier d'être venu directeur de la
communication troisième je rappelle que
votre école est aussi partenaire des
prix lumières on en a parlé il ya
quelques instants c'était lundi soir à
paris et puis toujours dans ce cadre il
ya des projections l encours et aux
clayes-sous-bois programme complet à
retrouver sur le site internet de
l'académie des lumières et il ya aussi
des portes ouvertes ce week end samedi
25 janvier dans votre établissement pour
ceux qui voudraient s'y inscrire c'est
aussi le moment pour les étudiants merci
on en revient aux élections municipales
elle se déroule les 23 et 30 mars
prochains pour les communes de plus de
1000 habitants et nouveauté car les
électeurs voteront à la fois pour le
conseil municipal mais aussi pour le
conseil communautaire le point sur
toutes ces modifications elles sont
complexes avec catherine de l'atome
voilà à quoi ressemblera demain votre
bulletin de vote lors des prochaines
élections dont le premier tour a lieu le
23 mars à gauche les listes des
candidats au conseil municipal
à droite la liste des candidats au
conseil communautaire car nouveautés du
code électoral les électeurs des
communes de plus de 1000 habitants votre
aussi pour les délégués qui siégeront
conseil communautaire
tous les conseillers communautaires
doivent apparaissent sur la liste
municipale et dans un dans un ordre bien
précis je rappelle que les conseils
municipaux sont paritaires c'est à dire
qu'il doit avoir un homme une femme un
homme une femme et ce sera la même chose
pour les consommateurs un homme une
femme une femme est généralement ce sont
les têtes dans les têtes de liste comme
municipales qui doivent se retrouver
dans la liste communautaire vous ne
pourrez pas rayer de nos ou en rajouter
les électeurs pourront se présenter pour
voter sans carte d'électeur mais
obligatoirement avec une pièce
d'identité que son une carte d'identité
ou un passeport
on peut présenter un titre d'identité
ces cartes nationales d'identité
passeports on peut aussi également
d'autres présenter d'autres types de
documents qui ne sont pas des titres
d'identité mais qui prouve quand même
sans son nom on peut par exemple
présenter une carte vitale avec
photographie et seulement avec
photographie canton candidats ils
devront tous se déclarer en préfecture
et en sous préfecture c'est une
nouveauté ils pourront prendre rendez
vous dès le 3 février ils devront
présenter des bulletins de vote au
format paysage avec des cotes très
précises un bulletins non valides sera
refusé le dépôt des candidatures s'ouvre
du 13 février au 6 mars trois semaines
au lieu d'une en raison des
modifications du code électoral un
renfort d'agents administratifs est
prévu des sites internet sont à la
disposition de ceux qui veulent en
savoir plus
nathalie renard est instructeur de krav
maga à guyancourt c'est par son porte
avec nous allons terminer ce journal un
portrait de sportifs passionnés qui est
inculte que des techniques de défense
accessible à tous anthony rech
il y a cinq ans nathalie renard souhaite
retrouver une activité sportive et
découvre le krav maga ancienne gymnaste
de haut niveau ses qualités physiques
lui ont vite permis de s'adapter aux
techniques de combat au bout seulement
de trois saisons l'élève passe le
diplôme d'instructeur je trouve qu'ils
avaient pas cette femme au cours voilà
et
et on avait quelques unes et c'est vrai
que quand on en discutant à l'extérieur
de cette activité sportive
beaucoup de femmes réagissait
j'aimerais bien essayé mais ça me fait
un peu peur non c'est trop violent non
c'est
nathalie la première femme française
diplômée de sa fédération et elle a fait
des émules puisque deux autres
structures il poursuivi en l'espace de
cinq ans elle a vu les attentes autour
du krav maga évolué quand j'ai commencé
le cra les élèves venaient pour
effectivement se défouler une activité
je dirais comme une autre presque est de
plus en plus
aujourd'hui nous ont posé des questions
mais voilà pourquoi vous voulez faire du
krav maga mais en fait des fois on n'a
même pas besoin de poser la question les
gens viennent et nous explique voilà moi
il m'est arrivé ça et j'aimerais bien
savoir un petit peu me défendre et c'est
utilisée à l'origine par les forces
spéciales israéliennes
le but du krav maga n'est pas de faire
des élèves déco bat hors pair mais
plutôt leur inculquer des techniques
d'attaqué défense permettant de se
sortir d'une situation difficile sains
et saufs
un peu trop d'agressions que vous ne
savoir se défendre avant de sa vague
récent fait que prendre part le coût
direct ou à la fin on prendre avec le
coup et avec l'armée traîner par terre
l'agresseur ça c'est bon ça marche en
deux ans les effectifs du club de krav
maga de guyancourt ont doublé passant de
50 à 105 adhérents 2014
on se retrouve demain vendredi pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'actus objet
d'histoire se heurter les filles elles
vous avez rendez vous avec claire
cambier pour fit l'écho les replays de
notre de nos différentes émissions sur
cette antenne sont à consulter sur le
site internet à la demande et
gratuitement excellente soirée
ouf